hello everyone you're probably all
wondering why is there a Gandalf light
person here home when usually there is a
chessboard there but this is this is
Henry Wordsworth Longfellow and he was a
poet and it is because of his poem that
the great American chess puzzler Samuel
Lloyd named his greatest chess puzzle
the Excelsior and well I'm just gonna
read it because it's I'm not really into
poetry but this sounds quite powerful
there in the Twilight called in grey
lifeless but beautiful Hill a and from
the sky serene and far a voice fell like
a falling star excelsior and this is
only the final verse of the poem I will
put the link to the entire poem into the
description below but let's get to the
puzzle this is the puzzle Sam Lloyd
created for us and it's it's one of the
greatest puzzles have ever seen
definitely and assembler it actually had
a bet with his friend mr. Dennis I
believe I don't I can't remember the
last name but his friend Dennis was also
a puzzle composer and his friend Dennis
claimed that any chess puzzle just show
him any just puzzle and he will be able
to tell you which piece does not deliver
mate but when Sam Lloyd managed to
finish this puzzle he couldn't tell
assembly which piece doesn't deliver
deliver mate and I tried I tried to give
my engine to solve this I gave him like
15 minutes and he still couldn't solve
it my engine manages to solve this but
he needs select world moves and you have
to solve this puzzle in 5 moves it's
possible to solve it in 16 17 18 in any
in any amount of moves but you have to
solve it in five moves and well since
this is probably like one of the most
famous puzzles ever most of you probably
already saw it but those of you who
haven't do try and solve it on your own
so it's white to move and its mate in
five so I'm saying do try and solve it
on your own you will feel very satisfied
even even if you don't solve it you'll
still feel great and
don't watch the video just you know
pause it and try to solve it and if you
don't solve it come back tomorrow okay
and the solution is well let's let's
analyze this a bit obviously the black
king is stuck here in the corner on h1
and if white would try and deliver
checkmate he would probably go about
rook f5 but if white played rook to f5
and this does threaten rook to f1
checkmate
but you can simply stop this by playing
rook to c5 now this rook can I go to f1
since it's pinned and after white
recaptures rook making five is no longer
possible so the correct idea here for
white is to play d4 and before is now
definitely threatening rook to f5
because if rook to f5 and dropped the c5
then pawn captures rook it's very simple
but black will black has to stop this of
course and the only way to stop
checkmate here is rook to c5 he has to
give up the rook so we have B captures
on c5 and now white is earth-threatening
rook to be won checkmate and the only
way to stop work to be one checkmate is
to play a 2 so okay this stopped rook to
be 1 checkmate and now white plays c6
and now white is again threatening rook
to f5 rook to f1 checkmate maneuver and
black has a couple of ways to stop this
him either either play Bishop to c7 or
he can play Bishop to g5 so if comes
there 5 this well Bishop for sacrificing
the bishop but not allowing white to
checkmate him five so let's see Bishop
to c7 and now what of course doesn't go
for up to f5 because a bishop therefore
will stop him for example drift f5 now
Bishop f4 captures an f4 b5 any move for
black and roofed f1 is checkmate but
this is in six moves so after Bishop to
c7 White has to continue in a different
fashion he has to play C capture some b7
and now white is threatening to capture
this night and there is no way to stop
this the night
go anywhere there is no way to capture
the pawn so after black makes any move
whatsoever for example Bishop captures
an g3
then white simply plays B captures an a8
grabbing either a bishop or a queen and
this is checkmate so yeah and this is a
the only way to do it and whatever black
plays it's still checkmate in five so
yeah do tell me did you enjoy the poem
did you read the entire poem and of
course did you manage to solve the
puzzle and if you haven't if you try to
use an engine I'm also interested was
your engine and your computer able to
solve it so yeah that's it for this
video I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here and if you're new to my channel
feel free to subscribe for more videos
and yeah that's it thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon